hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich darf euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zum ultimate
bumper cars autoscooters ich habe dieses
spiel auf steam entdeckt und dachte mir
mensch noch einen kleinen moment sonst
hast du die startphase verwendet
der typ hat mich also ich hab ich mal
kurz zeigen wie das vor der aufnahme war
und alle reden ins boot
viel besser als sie da ist
achtung alles einsteigen wir gehen
gleich richtig gut
[Musik]
foto junge wilde somit heißt gesucht
der typ da an der kasse hat mich auf
jeden fall schon die ganze zeit voll und
was er für eine komische haltung hat
stelle ich jetzt auch einfach mal nicht
in frage die sache jetzt auf jeden fall
dass ich dieses spiel entdeckt habe auch
sie dienen und nach gut wie im qualm
dann ruhte
da will ich das aber egal ja auf jeden
fall megawatt dieses spiel ist irgendwie
vier euro gekostet wurde dachte ich mir
das kann gut sein ich habe sogar extra
eine komplette wohnung nach diesem xbox
controller gewinnen der leuchten dann
wie ihr start ganz kurz das erklären ich
bin extra ausgesucht angeschlossen
bleibt nicht von beispiel mit tastatur
einer lieben freundin los geht s
los gehts meine lieben freunde wir
spielen la carte würde ich sagen das
hier sind unsere spieler die wir
auswählen können wir haben einmal pink
blau orange wir haben kommt alle rein in
den scooter es ist viel besser als sie
die ego shooter danke einmal verstanden
die teile hier können wir glaube ich
noch nicht fahren weil man erst mit 25
und 8 freigeschaltet hat von einem
schreiben sehr schönen seiten willkommen
lassen war ich würde sagen wir nehmen
einfach mal diesen lianen hier und
können nun auch noch einen fahrer aus
bildern einsteigen wir gehen gleich
richtig gummi alles klar bruder dass sie
noch ganz kurz meine person auswählen
also einfach mal eben hier zusammen ein
spieler
die gegner die sich ergeben wenn sie
mehr als die wahrscheinlich oder das
alles mit wem
diese aber wie die hier will sie noch
gute
alter
wie gebe ich denn dass ich die ganze wer
was geht nicht ich jedoch nicht mit dem
falter ist muss mit der ich wusste die
linke maustaste gedrückt halten damit
sich gastgeber ok hat ich weiß nicht wie
die anderen jetzt haben müssen aber kann
ich auch zurückgeschaltet
ich kann absolut verkennt jedoch diese
leute die so autoscooter so gefahren
sind die saßen auf jeden fall immer so
auf der kanzel von dem autoscooter mit
zum kölner dom arme und die sonne
enthält an dem golf festgehalten was so
gefahren zurück ist
dass diese leute jetzt
habe ich gerade nicht bekommen obwohl
ich nicht mal bin ich habe keine ahnung
was jetzt hier unsere mission ist wir
haben oben eingeblendet neues ziel und
oben links obwohl die kämpfe um mein
gott so
wir haben die gefühle die wir treffen
müssen beim autoscooter fahren hier kann
mir anscheinend glaube ich auch ein
bisschen verwirrt hier können wir unsere
leben wieder auffüllen wir haben nur
noch eine mini 20 stehen das heißt so
guck mal
das ist ein richtiger jahrmarkt wir
haben neue stil
aber
ich stehe gerade leute im autoscooter
würde mal sehen ich habe jetzt ein neues
ziel gekommen weiß nicht wo das ist aber
es wird wohl irgendwo sein also etwa
ganz kurz gas geben so stark dass wurden
rechts angeblich 100 km/h fahren der
hinten fährt unser ziel sie haben
[Musik]
die gäste star wars oder ein autoscooter
simulator wir haben unser ziel dort
hinten in der mauer
darunter zählt in der ecke und verharrt
junge vollgemacht mission erfolgreich
beendet jetzt haltet durch und sammeln
punkte wie sieht ein bisschen aus also
noch front aber ein bisschen gerhard
schröder vibes gibt mir dass gerade wir
haben auf jeden fall noch zehn sekunden
am start ich will noch einmal ganz kurz
mein leben auf bin ich immer dafür nach
exter punkte bekommen wenn man viel
leben hat vielleicht kompliziert doch
töten die alles oder so die möchte ich
ihnen heute noch ganz wenigen ganz
schnell
nur soll ein bisschen
ich bin platz 17
los geht's meine lieben freunde neue
runde neues glück wie gegen mich auf
alles die scheinst du
kleine
wir wird videoüberwacht sind gut also
unser typ hier wir brauchen auf jeden
fall namen für den schutz einfach mal
gustav gustav muss alles weg was denkt
ihr sie fünf wunderland
[Musik]
wieder ist aber nicht die durchgewirbelt
die stelle des alten bänke mit einem
grün bringt diesen premium scooter oder
wo ich sehe gerade wir haben sie dann
viel angegeben also wir dürfen uns gar
nicht dass kraft alles konzentriert ist
egal ob ist jenes keiner will ich ja
aber da
konfekt hat mir damals eine
gehirnerschütterung geholt beim
autoscooter fahren wir haben den schild
das heißt wir können so viel haben die
wir wollen wahrscheinlich damit gibt's
noch irgendein kobus
die feature oben rechts ich hab immer
jetzt schon mehr als in der letzten
runde von einer ganz fix eben nochmal
hier hinten unser leben aufhören sind
ein bisschen rasch hobby
arschloch nur ein ziel und das ziel
haben wir keine ahnung wo ich muss
allerdings ganz kurz erstmal mein leben
aufladen das so wir machen das nicht
komplett der macht das immer nur so ein
bisschen
alte durch um sammelpunkte okay das
heißt für mich aktuell ist die blöde
idioten nennt erstmals schuld
ja
warum bin ich denn schon wieder platz
elf ich will einmal in die top
platzierungen reihen plätzen immer
lieben freunde wir konzentrieren uns auf
die sieben ziele die wir für heute haben
ich weiß nicht wo das erste ziel ist ich
muss er erst mal gekonnt ein ausweichen
hat man sich einmal gefühlt die seinen
rennwagen fahrer werden oder ein
rennfahrer halt einfach wenn man halt
ausgewichen ist option nummer einsame
getroffen ziel nummer zwei waren habe
ich mein gehalt ist als ziel komme ich
betreibe hier vorne erst mal mit einer
schönen kurve bisschen leben auf für
einen tag nicht mal gegen die wand
gefahren ist unser nächstes ziel
befindet sich
die shiseido denn du bist dabei aber als
davor dass unser ziel und roche den weg
gibt
wir haben alles ist das unternehmen
mitten drin das war einmal richtig dumm
wenn man mittendrin dabei motto fun to
drive haben egal wer ist denn unser ziel
da vorne unser ziel ist ja heißt tina es
sind iby und ihn aber jetzt da wir sind
verdient so aus china aber auch so
wieder als nächstes hier vorne erst mal
schön schön abholen pikant macht ein
auge so bin ich selbst ganz am ende es
ist sich dort den habe ich gerade schon
gesehen den habe ich gerade schon zu
gehen da ran glas mich in ruhe patrick
viktor auf dich geht sagt junge so wir
haben vier ziele wir haben auch die
hälfte der zeit wir sind ein bisschen in
zeitnot
aber er braucht auch immer nur das ziel
zu geben sollte sind aber jetzt hinter
mir gesehen da und das ziel ist es ist
sandra gewesen die blöde idioten wollen
wir hier ganz fixiert aufladen und
weiter geht sie in oliver rahmen sollten
aber auch sechs von sieben und das
letzte ziel meine lieben freunde unser
siebtes team vielleicht sind wir dann
endlich ein neuer rang den wir dann
erreicht haben wir letztes ziel ist
diana so aber müssen wir mal ganz kurz
einmal durch youtube mich ja auch alle
backup zu diana
ich will doch nur
ich glaub ich musste von vorne begonnen
weil vorher rückwärts aulich liegt bei
dem dickkopf und daher von vorne die ist
aber auch mittendrin im chaos das machen
jedoch extra dass ich da nicht erkannt
oder aber jetzt geht durch zu dieser
idiot ich habe fast kein leben ja ok
toll gemacht mission endet aber
geschafft was kein leben ja ich wurde
ganz schnell zu leben freunde sind
so beim ok bisschen leben aufgeladen
hier vorne den schutzschild den brauche
ich auf jeden fall auch wir haben final
countdown leute 14 sekunden nur noch
keiner ist bisher rausgeflogen sandra
können wir aus gegen sandra brandt
sandra brandt meine lieben freunde
sandra ist raus wir haben noch drei
sekunden und wenn wir dann keine neuen
rang haben dann weiß ja auch nicht meine
stimme dieser marsch aber wir haben
ein scheiß staaten ihr spiel verlassen
so komplett raus sagt brauche ich nicht
ich weiß wie man auto scooter fährt und
zwar so
wenn er ein paar ihr scheiß sandras
victors und jana